in the apportionment of cease in the u.s
house of representatives
this is a unique ritual that has
occurred only 23 other times in american
history
i assured the president that the census
was complete
and accurate president biden will then
deliver the population counts
and apportionment results to congress as
required by law
but our work isn't over yet and we look
forward to delivering the redistricting
data
no later than september 30th
thank you for having me today and
congratulations on completing
yet another census thank you madam
secretary
this is a historic moment that happens
once every 10 years
and it is my honor to represent all of
the hard-working staff at the u.s census
bureau
who spent countless hours to ensure
everyone was counted
especially during the coven 19 pandemic
i also want to thank everyone who
responded to the census during these
extraordinary
times when the first census was being
conducted in 1790
congress expected about 2 million people
to be living in the country
when the results came back in 1793 the
population exceeded 3.9 million
and overnight the number of
congressional representatives grew by
40.
this number was so much larger than
anticipated that they had to add on to
independence hall to house all of the
new lawmakers
the first census was a critical step to
help build our the foundation of our
democracy
and as we've learned over the years it
continues to be a cornerstone of our
growing nation
through wars time to great social and
technological change
and during a global pandemic our nation
has taken the census
every 10 years as directed by our
constitution
a census is a massive operation that
takes years to plan
and it takes a community to see it come
to fruition
in addition to our dedicated staff we
had the support of hundreds of thousands
of national and local partners
and of course we had the help of our
respondents
who spent a few minutes completing the
2020 census form
the count began in january of 2020 in
the small alaskan village of tuxek bay
it was there we counted the first person
in the 2020 census
on march 12 2020 invitations to respond
to the census began to arrive in
mailboxes across the country
less than a week later states across the
nation began to impose stay-at-home
orders
immediately we knew we needed to adapt
we adapted our operations to protect the
health and safety of our staff and the
public
and we adapted our schedule to ensure we
could deliver high quality statistics
and later we adapted due to natural
disasters including
hurricanes and wildfires
through all of this we remain flexible
and practical
and persistent so that we could fully
conduct the 2020 census count
we were especially pleased to see how
two-thirds of the nation
completed the census on their own trying
to reach as many people as possible
we extended our communications campaign
and quickly developed new ads reflecting
life during the pandemic
we advertised on pizza boxes instead of
during basketball games
our partners joined us in reaching
people at food banks and school
cafeterias
instead of promoting the census at
county fairs we quickly expanded from 13
non-english languages to 46 languages
to assist in reaching additional
historically undercounted populations
we mailed additional reminders to
respond we emailed households in low
responding areas
and worked with colleges and
universities directly to ensure their
students were counted in the right place
we worked hard to get more people to
respond especially in those historically
undercounted areas
census takers have a hard job to begin
with and
trying to count people during a global
pandemic made it even more challenging
but in order to count the remaining
households that did not respond on their
own
our census takers went out to those
addresses equipped with masks and
iphones
and collected responses directly from
household members or from knowledgeable
neighbors
in some cases when we couldn't get a
response in any of these ways
we were able to use information
households already provided the
government
such as through past census responses
tax returns
or other government records as we move
into the results
i want to note that we appreciate the
public's patience as we took the
appropriate amount of time
to ensure the accuracy and quality of
the count
so with that let's get to the results
you've all been waiting for
the 2020 census took a snapshot of all
people living in the united
states on april 1st 2020 and the results
are in
according to the 2020 census the number
of people living in the united states
was
331 million 449
and eighty one
this represents an increase of seven
point four percent over the official
population count
from the 2010 census this population
growth rate is lower than the previous
growth rate
of 9.7 between the 2000 and 2010
censuses
in fact the growth rate from the 20 from
2010 to 2020
is the second slowest in u.s history the
country's 7.4
increase in population this decade was
only slightly more than the 7.3 increase
between
1930 and 1940.
for the regions the south grew the
fastest over the last decade
with the 10.2 increase in population
followed by the west with 9.2 percent
the northeast with 4.1 percent
and the midwest with 3.1
the northeast grew faster this decade
than it grew between 2000 and 2010
while the other three regions grew
slower this decade than the last
when looking across the states we see
large variation in population sizes
the state with the largest 2020 census
resident population
was california with thirty nine million
five hundred thirty eight thousand
two hundred and twenty three the state
with the smallest population was wyoming
with five hundred and seventy six
thousand eight hundred and fifty one
however the 10 most populous states each
had a resident population between 10
and 40 million
while the 10 least populous states each
has a resident population
between a half a million and 1.4 million
the population of most states grew
between 2010 and 2020
utah was the fastest growing state with
an 18.4
increase in population growing to 3.3
million
in 2020. on the other hand three states
lost population
with with west virginia having the
largest rate of decrease at 3.2 percent
the population of district columbia grew
by 14.6 percent
puerto rico's population decreased by
11.8 percent
to 3.3 million
now let's get to the apportionment
results from the 2020 census
the constitutional purpose of the census
is congressional apportionment
which is the process of distributing the
memberships or seats in the u.s house of
representatives
amongst the states every 10 years in a
way that is proportional to each state's
population
since 1941 the law has specified that
the method of equal proportions will be
used
to assign house seats to the states and
while the law does not require the
census bureau to calculate the number
of seats each state will get we do it as
a courtesy to the president
we apply the required method to the
apportionment population
of the 50 states not including the
district of columbia and puerto rico
because they have no voting seats in the
congress
the 2020 census apportionment population
includes the number of people living in
the 50 states
plus the overseas population which is a
count
of federal employees living overseas and
their dependents living with them
who are allocated to a home state
since 1940 the regional trend with
apportionment has been
an increase in the number of
congressional seats for the south
and west and a loss of congressional
seats for the north
and northeast and midwest more
specifically
since 1940 there's been a combined net
shift of 84 seats
to the south and west regions overall
the effect of the official 2020 uh
census
population counts on congressional
apportionment is a shift of seven seats
among 13 states
which is the smallest number of seats
shifting among the states in any decade
since the current method
of calculating apportionment was adopted
in 1941.
six states will gain seats in the house
of representatives
texas will gain two seats and colorado
florida montana north carolina and
oregon
will each gain one seat
seven states will each lose one seat in
the house california
illinois michigan new york ohio
pennsylvania and west virginia
the number of seats for the remaining 37
states will not change
the states that have the most
representatives in congress are
california with 52 seats
texas with 38 seats florida with 28
seats
and new york with 26 seats these four
states are the most populous in the u.s
with each having more than 20 million
people and together
those states will hold about a third of
the total seats in the house of
representatives
also each of the six least populous
states will have less than
one million people and will have only
one seat
after the first apportion occurred based
on the 1790 census
each member of the house represented
roughly 34
000 people now the average population
size
of each house district based on the 2020
census
will be 761 169 people
which is an increase of 50 402 people
per representative when compared to the
average
of 710 767 people per representative
based on the 2010 census
and those were the first results of the
2020 census
we have taken the time we needed to
produce the high quality statistics
that we and the public expect while no
census is perfect
we are confident that today's 2020
census results meet our high data
quality standards
we would not be releasing them to you
otherwise the census bureau is committed
to sharing what we
know when we know it to help the nation
understand the quality of the 2020
census results
despite all the challenges of the
pandemic the completeness and accuracy
of these first 2020 census results are
comparable with recent censuses
we had numerous quality checks built
into collecting the data
and we have conducted one of the most
comprehensive reviews in recent census
history during data processing
later today we will release the next set
of operational quality metrics and
additional quality indicators
this afternoon's release will be
unprecedented
and how soon after the census we are
able to provide operational metrics
down to the state level they are just
one of the many ways we evaluate and
assess the quality of the 2020
census while our assessments won't
change the results of the 2020 census
they will inform and influence our
planning for the next census
we are also looking forward to sharing
more 2020 census population results
with you later this year including
redistricting data
statistics on age sex race and ethnicity
and details about the center of
population the results for the u.s
island areas will also be provided
in a separate release at a later date
states as well as the public will
receive the data they need
to begin redistricting by august 16th
the census bureau will also deliver the
final redistricting data toolkit
to all states and the public by
september 30th
covet 19 related delays and prioritizing
the delivery of these apportionment
results today
delayed our original plan different from
previous censuses the census bureau will
deliver the data for all states at once
instead of on a flow flow basis finally
i want to take a moment again
to thank our tireless hardworking staff
for everything they have done to ensure
the delivery of today's data
and future data releases from the 2020
census and i want to thank the millions
of people who completed the 2020 census
on their own
or provided information to our census
takers thank you
michael back to you
thank you ron we will now begin taking
questions
from credentialed media about the first
2020 census population results
members of the media who registered
receive the phone number
via email from our eventbrite account
when asking a question please include
your name and media affiliation
operator can you please provide the
instructions for calling in
if you would like to ask a question per
r1
a mute your line and name media
affiliation when prompted
to draw star 2
again to ask a question press star 1.
thank you to all the speakers all of the
results
today are available on our website at
census.gov
you will find many materials related to
well we callers let me introduce our
census bureau's
matter experts to us we have us today
ron john director of the census bureau
al fontenot assist
associate director for city consensus
victoria valkov the associate director
for demographic programs karen battle
chief of population christian concept
she's our schedule for the 2020 census
approach
opportunity in the population event
operator our
um
um
we did uh do a very thorough job
especially
uh in those areas making sure that we
counted everybody
um you know i think we we saw from our
population estimates that the population
growth
had slowed significantly and i think
that that
you know some folks's uh projections
might have been based on
on slightly higher uh population growth
projections but
you know i'm not the demographer on on
the call here so maybe i'll turn it over
to
tory or karen to give a little bit more
insight into that
hi there good afternoon um so what i'll
just mention
is that for the state of texas and for
the state of florida
um the 2020 census counts were actually
below our population estimates from
vintage 2020.
now for texas in florida the difference
between the 2020 census count
and the estimates was within about one
percent so they were still close
but the 2020 counts were slightly lower
than our population estimates
thanks for that karen operator do we
have our next call
our next question comes from zach
matteler with politico your line is open
hi there hey all right thanks thanks for
doing this thank you for taking
questions um
i want to follow a little bit on mike's
question we saw um you know rhode island
didn't lose a seat like we was widely
expected florida and texas kind of
gained less
again i kind of want to reiterate um do
we have any estimations for why
the population the earlier population
estimates were you need over
undershooting
and what is the bureau's level of
confidence in this count given
uh everything that's happened over the
last year given the pandemic given all
the changes to the schedule what's the
level of confidence these results
thanks for that line of questioning i'll
pass that back to our demographic
experts to talk about the quality of our
data but then specifically your
questions that asked about
the apportionment results tori thanks
for that question
we are very confident in the data that
we released today
we measure the quality of the census in
many different ways and one of the ways
that we measure the quality of the
census
is to compare to our population
estimates of course our population
estimates are based on the last census
and built forward adding birth
subtracting deaths adding in
migration so most states
are within one percent of our population
estimates which makes us feel very good
about those
census counts
right thanks for that line of
questioning
operator do we have our next caller
our next question comes from beyond a
bearish back with star trek
your line is open hi
thanks for taking my question i was
wondering if someone could talk a little
bit more about how the seats that were
narrowly expected to
lose like minnesota and preliminary
numbers were going to lose what's going
to lose one of his state seat
how it held on could high participation
have contributed to something like that
for that line of questioning and again
um i'll lean in and and toss this back
over to our demographic
uh directorate experts to talk a little
bit about the count
itself um and as you stated um those
states that lost the seat or
or were on the verge of gaining a seat
okay well i'll start um thank you for
that question
i want to repeat what my colleagues have
said
we're very confident in the quality of
the data
and we've worked hard to ensure that the
data that we're using to calculate
enforcement is correct
as far as how certain scenarios may have
impacted the results of apportionment we
don't tend to
speculate on that we just use the counts
that come from the decennial census
after they've been finalized so um
we will continue to look into the
quality of the data as we move forward
thank you kristin and thank you caller
for that question
operator we have our next caller
alday with the saint louis post dispatch
your line is open
hi everyone thanks so much for having me
um i
uh really just need a couple of basic uh
data points from you i'm the data
reporter
here at the post can you please just
tell me what the population of missouri
is and what the population of illinois
is
what i'm going to suggest for you if you
don't mind
we have population or public affairs
specialists that are on our
our coms line in pio if you could
contact them at pio
census.gov or 301-763-3030 we'll get you
those numbers
right away so you can file your story
okay
can you still hear me here um
is that information not searchable on
your data portal
right now well ma'am um we're actually
conducting a live
conference or news conference and a q a
and some of our smes don't have
the database at their fingertips so just
to expedite
getting you that response i wanted you
to reach out to our public information
office
um if that's quite all right by you okay
yes i will do that thank you so much
thank you so much and thank you for your
continued interest in the 2020 census
operator can we have our next caller
clark with pbs public broadcasting your
line is open
hi can you hear me we can loud and clear
all right great um so just looking at
new york specifically and
giving your answer to the last reporter
i'm not sure if you know but
just looking at new york specifically is
there any indication of where new york's
population
is going in terms of which states they
are
moving toward that we're losing people
to and
can any of you tell me how close new
york was to losing
a second congressional seat
yes we have information on that now pass
that over to our
demographic director specialists or
experts
tori thank you karen
actually i was just going to start and
say that we do know
from our population estimates that the
state of new york has experienced
negative net domestic migration meaning
there were more people moving
out of the state of new york over the
last decade and moving
into the state i don't have right here
information on specifically which states
people were moving to but that's
something that could be discussed with
subject matter experts at the census
bureau
and can i just add that actually new
york
grew between the 2010 census
and the 2020 census by about 4.2 percent
thanks for that i was just going to
follow up on the last part of the
question
um she asked how close
new york was and so what we have is that
if
new york had had 89 more people they
would have
received one more seat instead of
the last state that received their last
seat
there were 435 seats so the last seat
went to minnesota
and new york was next in line and if you
do the
algebra equation that determines how
many they
would have needed it's 89 people but
that's
if you hold the population of all other
states
constant wait can you still hear me
sorry
we can't so if we had counted
89 more people in new york state
and assuming everything else was
constant we would not have lost a
congressional seat
correct thank you
thank you for that sir operator do we
have our next caller
jim jacobs with gbwire.com your line is
open
hi there
can you hear us
hello hello hello we can hear you loud
and clear now we can hear you uh
excellent sorry my
button got pushed there sorry guys it's
jim jacobs of tvwire.com
my question is very similar to the
gentleman's in new york but i want to be
more
california-centric and specific because
that's where i am at can you talk to me
about the shifting demographics in the
state of california
uh inflow versus outflow and how close
were we to losing
a potential second seat or in the case
of new york how close are we to not
losing
one seed that makes sense thank you
thanks for that line of questions and
because it's about the data results i'll
turn that back over to
our demo experts
hi there this is karen battle um so with
the
state of california i can tell you is
that from our population estimates
program
we know that over the last decade
that california has actually
experienced natural increase where they
were able to gain population because
there were more births and deaths
and they also had positive net
international migration
uh but california did have negative net
domestic migration
where again there were more people
moving out of california than moving
into california
and so that contributed to the um
the population count and census
thanks for that karen operator do we
have our next caller
i'm sorry i'll go ahead go ahead
he was waiting for the rest of the
answer which is he asked about how close
california was
um and what i can tell you is that as
you as i said before
there's 435 seats if you continue down
the rankings
california was at number 441
so that's about six steps down from
gaining the nexi thank you for that
kristen
operator do we have our next caller
jamie weiss with 40 29 news your line is
open
hi good afternoon can you hear me you
can loud and clear
hi there this is jamie weiss with 40 29
news i'm not sure if you can
answer the specifics i'm calling about
arkansas and oklahoma states in the
south where
they're next to big states like texas
that have seen an increase in population
i'm curious
if you've seen any data about growth in
those states but why maybe they haven't
received a congressional seat and why
they haven't lost any congressional fees
either
thanks for that line of questioning um
and again i'll pass this over to our
demographic
experts
um in terms of whether why a state has
not
gained or lost a seat um it all depends
on the population distribution
for any given decennial census so
if their population in relation
proportional relation to the other
states hasn't changed
then they won't gain or lose a seat
thanks for that kristin um operator do
you have our next caller
hi katos with politico your line is open
hi it's shia kappus with the illinois
playbook in politico
can you talk a little bit about the
in-migration out-migration of illinois
and how close was it from losing a
second seat
and is there a chance that block by
block information will be released a
little bit earlier than september
thanks for that line of questioning and
we'll take this right back to our
demographic experts for a little
explanation
um albeit be mindful of the fact that
um the the set of data that we've
released today is only down to the state
level as far as the geography is
considered
but there will be more to come and and
more details to follow as we continue to
to disseminate the results of the 2020
census
demo so i'll
i'll start um so illinois was actually
one of the three states that actually
lost population
over the last decade and we know from
our population estimates program
that the state of illinois actually had
negative net
domestic migration again there were more
people moving out
of that state than moving into that
state
and i think i'll turn it over to kristin
to talk more about
uh the next part of your question
um as far as how close they were to
losing
another seat um i don't have that in
front of me because that would require
me to look
up in the rankings you know above 4 35
to see how far
how close they were to c435
but when i look at the states that were
direct the 10 states that were directly
below
c435 illinois is not among them so
illinois was not
close to getting uh or to not losing
another seat if that makes sense
thanks for that kristen reporter
operator do we have our next dollar
lynn sweet with chicago sun times your
line is open
uh thank you i don't want to sing that
there's a lot of in my interest
but i want to follow up with my
colleagues from missouri and and from
the illinois playbook
uh could you make it perhaps a little
clearer
is the loss not so much so we lost
population in illinois
but was it really more of a matter that
other states just had such big
gains that even if we had held steady we
might have lost a seat
meaning was it really our loss or was it
because other states
just gained more that we lost the seat
coming right back to you demo
um we can't really
comment i mean we can't really speculate
on that because
it's it's all about the dis distribution
overall
um what you're stating could possibly be
true
but um without digging into it a lot
more deeply we wouldn't know
exactly the reason why one state loses
or gains because it's the calculation is
done as a whole
on all the states together and how
they're proportionally related
but theoretically if certain states
gained a lot more
than other states but proportionally
then they would be more likely to gain
seats
thank you for that kristen operator
we have our next caller
roxanne scott with wabe news your line
is open
okay thank you can you hear me i hope so
yeah
yes okay thank you um i wanted to know
and similar to new york um how far
off was georgia in either gaining or
losing a seat
in the house thanks for that question
um we'll have our demo experts
address that on the questioning this is
georgia
gaining or losing a seat um
this answer is similar as far as i don't
know how close they were
above the number seat 435
as to you know whether they might have
lost or not
named one but um when you go below
this the number 435 to see the states
that almost received another seat
they are not among that that list of the
10 next
states so they weren't close to
receiving one more than they got
thank you for that operator
do we have our next caller
pat clooney with indiana gazette your
lawn is open
yes good afternoon thank you very much
oh that is indiana pennsylvania for what
it is worth
and pennsylvania uh i don't know what
specifics you have for the keystone
state did pennsylvania
gain population but just not enough of a
gain to um
offset the possible law to defeat
thanks for that thanks for that let me
toss this over to demo and see if we
have any data that we can share for your
insights on
on the state of population specifically
and and for all the callers who are
calling about specifics um
uh in relationship to totals of of pop
change and things of that nature
i want to remind everyone that after
today's news conference we will be
posting
our news release as well as tables that
support this release
that will assist you in finding those
discrete variables but also
another pitch for the public information
office you can always reach out to us
if you by chance you don't get to ask
your question during uh today's
news conference we'll more than well
we're more than welcome and willing to
help you
um get those direct answers so tossing
this back over the demo
hi i just checked uh one of the tables
that will be posted
online or may have already been posted
online
depending on how we're doing with our
live posting
for pennsylvania it was 2.4
increase between 2010 census and 2020
census
was there more to the question i can't
remember
is the caller still there
i think that that addresses it thanks
for that
operator do we have our next caller
toby vance with mississippi broadcasting
your line is open
thank you i was curious about which
states and i heard y'all say the south
saw the
largest growth in population which
states saw the largest growth
and which states saw in that region uh
the
lowest growth rate
thanks for that question um about the
data and so um
we'll we'll take that data question back
to our demo
experts to see if they have that
information at at radio
at their fingertips demo um
i don't have the list of the states
within the south
that had the largest increase but i do
have the states the top five states that
had
the largest uh percent increase um
and that was utah idaho texas
north dakota and nevada those states had
the largest percent increase between
2010 and 2020.
thank you for that operator you have our
next caller
mark cavett with the oakland press your
line is open
i'm mark yes yes hi this is mark kevin
at the oakland frets just wanted to
talk about michigan specifically losing
one seat in the u.s
house how close was michigan to losing
uh
two seats and you know talk about the
decrease in population there in michigan
that led to this
uh losing of one seat
thank you for that line of question
about michigan um turning back to our
data experts and the demographic
director
um so i again i don't have
the part about what's above the 435 but
as far as the next 10 states in the
ranking that
that just missed getting another seat um
michigan
is uh in number 444 in the ranking
which means that you know if they they
could have potentially been closer to
not losing a seat um
however i just want to mention that for
all these questions
about how close a state was and if you
want to see
the part that i'm talking about that i i
can't i don't have
with in front of me uh that are above
435
uh on the 2020 census apportionment
results webpage there is a priority
values table
that should be posted and that will give
you
the ranking order of all of this
of the seat and the states that just
missed below it as well
thanks for that kristen because we know
that it's very important for people to
see themselves in the data
especially with this important release
that we're putting out today
operator do we have our next caller
jeff reddick with wsyxabc6 your line is
open
hi you're all able to hi there we can
loud and clear
we're here we're here in um columbus
ohio and
uh central ohio here is a part of a
state that experiences significant
growth
um so i'm wondering how nitty-gritty you
can get in terms of
where ohio is is lagging in population
growth where else is holding the state
back
thanks for that one one disclaimer or
some air cover for our demo experts who
are getting a lot of questions today
i want to remind everyone all the
reporters and
media outlets that are covering today's
release today's release
um takes us down to the state level when
we talk about
populations and values and counts so
um there is more to come with the 2020
census and future
uh releases when we get below the state
level which i think will give you some
insights into
some of the questions that that you're
asking but i'll turn it over to the demo
and allow them to
to give you information they do have to
share today
hi there so again what we can tell you
is about
ohio's growth as state
and ohio's population grew by 2.3
percent
uh over the last decade and as michael
mentioned once we have
um our next data release the
redistricting data we'll be able to look
more
uh within the state and look at
different areas of growth
and see how the growth was faster or
slower
and make those comparisons at that time
anecdotally can you say how ohio matches
up with the rest of the midwest
well i believe we showed information
earlier today that showed that
actually the midwest and the northeast
um their growth overall was three or
four percent
over the last decade and that's in
comparison to the south and the west
where we
saw about 9.2 and 10.2 percent growth
thank you for that karen and operator do
we have our next caller
malachi barrett with ends live your line
is open
thank you hopefully you can hear me and
um my colleague mark here in michigan
actually
knocked out a couple of questions that i
was curious about so
if i also ask if the coronavirus
you know states that were impacted more
severely
throughout the pandemic if that created
any kind of disproportionate impact on
you know the ability to accurately
record
accounts in those states obviously
michigan has
some significant struggles with that
thanks for that line of questioning um
we can definitely
give you a little bit about the um the
data but
i'd like to if at all possible allow um
al fontenot to give us a little bit of
information about the quality
of our operation in particular the
impacts
uh due to the pandemic and the things
that we did to ensure
a complete and accurate account
thank you michael we worked very hard to
coordinate
data from the cdc from state and local
governments to ensure that when we sent
people out into the field
we were sending them out at a time when
the local community
would tolerate or be more open to
door-to-door
enumeration and what we found was by
delaying
some of our field operations we were
able to go into the field
and successfully collect the data in
errors that had high culvert impacts
early in the colvit
outbreak and we feel very confident
that we did a good job of collecting
data in spite of the covet 19
output
thank you al
operator do we have our next caller
rachel hoffmeyer with nbc26 your line is
open hi thank you guys so much for
taking questions um
i've already emailed that email to try
and get as much data as possible because
i understand the numbers aren't in front
of you but is there anything
wisconsin specific you guys can share i
know two of our neighbors experienced
losses in the midwest was like you said
the slowest
region in terms of growth so just
curious if there's any insight you could
share about wisconsin
thank you for that um let's take a look
or let's
check in with demo and see what we can
like we can chat on the midwest and
wisconsin in particular specifically
um wisconsin did have a
3.6 increase in their population between
2010 and 2020 which as karen mentioned
is
uh in line with the midwest
as a whole do you want to add anything
to that karen
um no i i don't think we have uh
additional
data at our fingertips at this
particular moment for wisconsin
thank you thanks for those loving
questions as well um
operator do we have our next caller
olivia winslow with news day your line
is open
thank you very much for uh taking my
call i just did get the
numbers from the cio office but i wanted
clarification in the name of the
demographer who made the statement i
didn't catch it
i'm i represent i'm in new york so i'm
concerned they're interested in the new
york results and so
the demographer who mentioned that new
york new york had had
89 and is that right just 89
uh more people it would not have lost a
congressional seat
confirm that please and tell me the name
of the person who said it thank you
hi olivia this is michael cook that was
christian cos lap
and if you go to our electronic press
kit you'll see her name
and title um it was kristin coslap who
made that statement
i don't know kristen if you have
anything else for one of 89
people you know i mean that one percent
uh differential uh that you're talking
about that
89 people would be much less than that
so
ah wow i
that's a big loss for just 89 people
anybody want to comment on that
um i can just confirm that the number
when you calculate it is 89
um however um it's not
on you i mean it's part of the standard
of the method of equal proportions is
that it all depends on the overall
proportion of all the states within the
nation
and so uh for example it's not unusual
for
there to be a small margin like that for
in uh
in 1970 utah only need 231
people to uh move up from the 436 to the
435th
ranking value
thank you for that kristen operator do
we have our next caller
and a favor with columbus dispatch your
line is open
hi can you guys hear me again loud and
clear
oh great um i uh i wanted to ask
about ohio i know you just spoke with a
a reporter about new york but i wanted
to ask um
you know where did ohio sit on that
chart if new york was just below the
line was
ohio like a thousand people off or were
we more closer to like we barely kept
from losing two seats if that makes
sense
it does make sense let me um toss this
over to christian kozlov
to see if she has that information right
in front of her if she doesn't
we'll work on getting that for you from
our
pio call-in number kristen
what i do have is that ohio was next in
line behind new york so
they were at ranking number 437
um so they were uh close as well
to not the two receiving or to receiving
one more seat than they did
thanks for that kristen operator we have
our next caller
howard fisher with capital media service
your line is open
thank you i appreciate you guys taking
the calls and i know that
a lot of us are waiting for some of the
data to be posted but
like all of us i need to be parochial uh
arizona was one of the fastest growing
states historically
yet we didn't gain an anticipated seat
how far off
were we in terms of of having that seven
ex that 767 000 or whatever it was
to get a a tenth seat
thanks howard for that question i'll let
demo uh speak to that
um that line of questioning about your
state
um for arizona they were uh ranking
number
440 as far as the states that were just
below
the cut off to to receive one more seat
then they
would um i i don't have the numbers
in front of me for all of those lower
states as far as how much they would
need
to um okay so essentially we we we
weren't
as close as oh as ohio and and new york
so we
we weren't it's not even a question that
we were just below the line we just
didn't didn't get there
correct okay great and now we'll
when we finally get this stuff posted if
i keep hitting refresh
on the uh on what's supposed to be the
kit
we'll have the specifics in terms of
all of that state by state
um there's a table called priority
values
a priority values table for the 2020
census
but it will be closer to the bottom of
the
2020 census apportionment results
webpage which
should be live soon and you should be
able to get to it from the apportionment
press kit
webpage that will show you all of the
rankings
um for seats 51 because
each state gets one to start with so the
rankings from seat 51
to about 460. okay so
you'll be able to see how far below
right and to the extent that somebody in
the fire office could get that posted
now you might
end up avoiding a lot of these questions
but thank you much
thank you thank you
operator do we have our next caller
michelle quesada with wptv your line is
open
hi i have two questions um one they're
both
are you there michelle
are you there michelle
it looks like michelle may have gotten
disconnected
okay we have our next caller
please our next question comes from
carla valdez with unit vizion your line
is open
hi can you hear me we can loud and clear
perfect i know there was an increase on
population in texas
do we know uh if the hispanic
population increased too
thanks for that um i'll let demo shed
some light on
on that data and that specific
characteristic for
the population in texas hi there
um so at this point we have uh
processed population totals
and we are now beginning a process of
um processing the characteristics data
uh collected in the 2020 census so data
on race and hispanic origin
age and sex so at this point in time we
actually don't
have uh vital final numbers to share uh
about the hispanic population uh at this
time
thanks for that question and thanks for
that response karen operator
i think we're gonna go and take our last
question
our last question comes from frank
lockwood
with arkansas democrat gazette your line
is open
thank you i was wondering if you could
talk about
what the south is seeing as far as uh
immigration live births some of those
things
and also you've got a chart that shows
priority
values for the 2020 census apportionment
there are three arkansas places on there
can you explain how the priority value
system works thanks for that
question about priority values i'll toss
that over too
i believe it looks like uh cory valkov
uh
nope sorry i care no no i think it's
it's kristin that is the
expert on that i can answer the part
about the priority values but if uh
if karen wants to follow up to talk
about the
um the shifts in population for the
south
she could do that for the priority
values the way the method of equal
proportions works
is that we calculate uh
numbers priority values is what we call
them
that are based on each state's
population and the number of potential
seats each state could receive
and we calculate you know as many of
those as could potentially be received
up to like 670 i believe and and then we
rank all of those values um
and then take number 51
through 435 and assign
to each state and then any number
any state that had a number below that
435 did not get another c
and you can also read about this in more
detail in the blog that we put out today
about how we calculate apportionment
and um i'll just add that in terms of
the population
growth in the south there really are
different reasons for the growth
i don't have kind of aggregated
statistics just for
the south but there are states like
texas
and florida that definitely are
experiencing
natural increase again more births than
deaths
and these types of states are also
experiencing a lot of
uh migration net migration uh be it
people moving
internationally into those states or
people moving domestically into those
states so there's more of that
moving into the state than people moving
out of the state
thank you to all the speakers all of the
results discussed today
are available on our website at
census.gov
you will find many materials related to
the release of the first 2020 census
results including
an america account story a blog a news
release and links to the statistics
and maps in our apportionment press kit
in about two hours we will release the
next set of 2020 census operational
metrics through an
interactive dashboard along with the
blog
with additional quality indicators
available in a working
paper and blog please visit census.gov
to access information
members of the media please contact pio
census.gov
or call 301-763-3030 for any additional
questions
a live presentation in spanish will
follow the news conference
media interested in obtaining spanish
language sound bites
should remain on this live stream thank
you all for joining us
the census bureau is proud to bring you
the first results of the 2020 census
we will now take a brief break for our
spanish language presentation
you